or
alors ça il donc on est lancé on est
live donc aujourd'hui on va suivre le
premier quart de finale du speech est ce
donc entre sarine et échappant
donc gré tout à fait cela yes donc à
noter les résultats précédents de
diffusion du final rapport qui gagnent
ses ennemis à 14h30 contre sarah n'a
sans la main grand prodige russe
et sarine par contre qu'il a gagné avec
15 et demi à 10,7 me contre grid souk
great souk ancien champion du monde de
blessés trois heures je cois
salle d'audience et indécis tous ces
matches on a vu la cadence à ses fins à
ça peut aller très vite à faux pas de
calais jura c'est clair ça va envoyer
faire vite et hyper chaud alors tout à
l'heure en off on attendait un petit peu
avec avec kevin on s'est posé la
question si si on avait des favoris dans
ce match alors malheureusement on est on
est d'accord sur ça voilà normalement
n'aurons pas d'accord mais
bon disons qu'on a chacun notre favori
est le favori en fait je pense enfin on
pense toujours que c'est lahoud cider du
coup sarine qui à 17 ans seulement et 26
62 hafid qui entrait dans son classement
exact mais pour tout dire j'ai déjà
perdu à contrôler et à
cappelle-la-grande café de la pente
quand il avait 11 ans ils étaient 300 à
près de 1450 et déjà déjà on sentait que
ça est un
gd prévenu l'avait battu de grands
maîtres avant et pour le coup même en
étant prévenu envoyait kidal est il est
grandiose ce jeune homme qui était un
petit gamin à l'époque
super joueur mais ça me dis à tous ceux
formant à cappelle-la-grande j'avais
jamais vu les lie avec des articles sur
lui dans je crois dans les journaux et
où il est sorti vous avez vu ça
et puis richard rapport avec ce rapport
c'est c'est un symbole c'est un joueur
hongrois
il a eu cet art oui oui tout autant
faire j'ai ma place est très
caractéristique pour un joueur de ce
niveau à quoi enfin il est fou sur
l'échiquier potentiellement quoi il faut
aussi se calmer mais je sais pas ce
qu'on va voir mais il est assez il est
peut être un excentrique
et ça commençait
donc
on s'est mis du côté de nuit à la sarine
avec avec les noirs en bas parce que
j'ai toujours pour lui simplement donc
pour le format là y'a juste pour vous
pour vous rappeler un petit peu le
format
donc on aura 90 minutes de 5 monsieur
ensuite une heure de trois plus humain
et une demi heure depuis le plus une
bien sûr sans compter c'est à la table
de se poser est donc vous aurez droit
donc bon alors pour l'instant on n'a pas
mis les calmes des joueurs parce qu'on
est un petit problème sur un sur vos
mains mais j'espère que ce sera réglé
pour leur deuxième portion de
dudu du match
donc
en tout cas c'est 2k speed et sa part
simplement pour tourner une trop pauvres
ce qui voit là aussi assez modeste donc
trompeuse ce qui est ce que mon c'est
une ouverture qui est quand même pas
très très joué à un haut niveau
est ce que tu penses que c'est une
ouverture qui aurait préparé pour cours
pour le match ou
alors il peut en fait il peut tout jouer
c'est assez fantasque après nyan win a
choisi une ligne justement plutôt solide
puisqu'il a joué avec des symptômes
deuxième va pas jouer il il a pas il n'a
pas il n'a pas été dans les dents les
complications et oui la ville classement
ils connaissent tout a vraiment céder
des joueurs au niveau d'un championnat
du monde à ces financements on voir quel
point les joueurs sont préparés
là c'est déjà c'est déjà hyper
intéressant je m oppose ski c'est
agressif c'est ce qu'il veut il veut
mettre la pression à régler blanc c'est
dans son si le show
d'accord et c'est vrai que
sharapova et na c'est le style de verre
qui joue les choses un petit peu
moi
un peu enfin excentrique quand tu disais
des choses qui se joue un peu moins
qu'ils ont un peu plus rares l'inclusion
acr en particulier et je pense que c'est
vrai que ça va
tenir ses promesses un parce que on va
le jeune fille marine 17 ans qui à la
barre kia qui a fait un très beau match
contre contrevient tout cas ça rime qui
est connu pour
dans son niveau de blé de stenay assez
incroyable
et ce comme l'envoi qui la 3200
quasiment donc c'est quand même su quand
même balle est assez solide c'est plutôt
pas mal et et aux varices un rapport qui
a bâti la 27 stands 10 à vide qui qui
progresse et que donc franchement c'est
un match super attendu et donc c'est pas
les matches avec on n'a qu'à écrire
xterra mais c'est quand même un match
bien parti leader qui est hyper
intéressant et pour commencer à faire
des supers stars du jeu a très
clairement avancé c'est des monstres
dont on ne peut pas dire que ce soit un
petit marché bat d'ailleurs riccio que
il en a fait les frais comme tu le
soulignes twitter bon il s'est fait
vraiment c'est maintenant bien détruire
d'emplois c'est
serré indécis et c'est chaud d'ailleurs
ses choix la position a déjà déjà assez
complète double grotte
alors juste pour répondre à vos carreaux
1527 oui robin sax et géante iphone en
fait je sens où mais j'ai voulu
récupérer les gammes des joueurs et en
fait j'ai un petit carré à droite
en fait les partage d'écran des joueurs
et aussi les cannes et j'arrive pas à
sélectionner un sac à main c'est un peu
c'est un peu chelou ce qui se passe chez
moi donc j'ai préféré que se montrer
avec stéphane on n'a pas trouvé d'autre
moyen que de se mettre en grand en fait
c'est ça le truc a le même accepté alors
attends je vais essayer de le faire
offre
un mode studio et ben je vais je vais
commenter alors je prends le litre sur
le ce commentaire on vous voyez à que
kony un sari n'est entré en possession
car alliances à la carte avec pour
objectif de commencer à ramener du monde
à la fête sur le roi blanc et par
anticipation on a vu le joli roi de
richert importe comme ça à tout moment
et peut amener sa tour peut-être bien
pour consolider et tenir normalement on
n'essaie pas trop toucher les pions à 2
et b2 à régler blanc pourquoi pour ne
pas s'affaiblir voyait phocéen c'est une
autre façon de jouer ou bien en pire
pour un élève ses deux fous en défense
il veut et il va essayer de faire la
différence
richard importe sans doute à l'est le
roi ou au sort cela semble assez logique
voilà et
on en profite pour dire bonjour à tous
ceux qui nous suivent d'or dans le tchat
fatouma d'or robin side qui aide qui est
sans doute
ses fans voilà
alors qu'est ce qu'on va voir maintenant
qu'est ce qu'on a comme l'or avec le
relais pour moi vous voyez hein je pense
assez simple ça va être de mettre le feu
sur le suroît blanc tous les pièces
pointe de faire ce côté-là et bat pour
les blancs c'est soit la réaction
centrale soit la réaction allait la
halle et le roi c'est l'air plutôt sympa
quand même
pour les noirs ça semble un peu plus
facile de jouer juste le plan est assez
logique d'aller attaquer d'aller
attaquer avec ses pulls droit ces deux
länder normalement mais deux rois ils
sont mais en tout cas on peut voir sans
doute trop arriver donc à trois noirs
donc à 3 blanc vient d'être jouée et la
grosse casse b3 et présent on devrait
avoir été remanié à 5 qui arrive
rapidement pour profiter de la case d3
le knb si je le vois bien arrivée sur la
terre c4 et le cavalier l'autre
cavaliers en assam b3 là c'est quand
monsieur j'ai un petit peu difficile
pour richard fleisher rapporte et les
sous pression il est sous pression m
facile du tout vous voyez d'ailleurs
trois minutes qu'on soit 200 jeunes
d'indication
sur ta forme que je les caméras très
simpliste d'un bloc de foie j'ai écrit
hannigan pour se voir pendant la pause
parce que quand un rom en principe
ça m'apprendra en fait quand je fais
quand je fais capture de fenêtres et là
il ne prend que le partage des francs en
tête de sarine et du coup maintenant un
peu de ça et l'épousé n'est pas le cas
mais
c'est très bizarre et quand je
[Musique]
je vais essayer différemment mais
alors du coup c'est enfin je continue le
commentaire de la partie on voit toutes
les pièces voire sais pas s'il a
commenté encore c'est pas pour toi en
termes techniques ça doit être plus
compliqué malheureusement et moi nous
contenter de m'occuper des échecs j'ai
de la chance j'ai de la chance en plus
c'est vraiment
une attaque assez basique que met en
place sonia sarine et pendant ce temps
là bas richard importe quand même
logiquement réagi aux deux sens
c'est assez logique et est ce que les
deux caroline ramond
vont permettre de de valider la tacc la
taille ne s'est pas facile de savoir
comment on va faire ici je ne sais pas
comment avancer si vous voulez ok je
mets mes deux cavaliers à
y insérer il a créé par l île place adam
l'aféas qu'est ce qu'on fait oui cela
risque de nous faire taire une voix
n'était pas le cas mardi avec moi c'est
un truc qui va être un souci aux
problèmes et les cavaliers noirs sont
huit ans et blessé mais en fait pas
grand chose à faire pour l'instant et
quimper de fouché du land le psg perd 10
peut avoir
le report a pas
un petit sacrifice de mix
et la souffrance interdire d'être jouée
en natation que 1
là c'est bizarre parce que là il ya
peut-être de moi ya beaucoup de
cavaliers prend des cassettes dans le
dab et servir de dettes au caire
maintenant 66 p comme il ya vis-à-vis
sur madame fait il enlevait
et là ça veut bien
ça devient un petit peu critique c'est
pas compliqué mais je préfère tellement
avant les voir en pratique comme cette
position et du cavalier prend des
querelles voir cavaler c1 qui traîne
tout le temps
[Musique]
c'était facile à savoir
la part de joueurs
bon pour l'instant oui quand tu dis tu
as on préfère toujours attaquer le roi
je crois assez mal c'est ce qu'on peut
dire en partie
directe place et c'est plus direct en
oublie c'est évidemment dans cette
attaque et quel droit un projet
professionnel c'est je pense le style
qui nous
oui mais je constate quand même qu'après
au niveau justement bailly va jouer la
position quoi à séverac ne roule pas
trop - malheureusement jusqu au même jeu
en fait ouais c'est vrai c'est assez
agacé c'est vraiment cela et il arrive
des fois dans les positions qui
visuellement n'est donc pas trop envie
bah il arriva à défendre et même à
contre-attaquer et là la position des
blancs est donnée partante l'envi mort
voir mireille ne trouve pas la couleur
pure
mais non mais il ya une personne en fait
on est à plus de vigilance terme
commencent à travailler de l'autre côté
actuelle dessus tu souligne el pais en
relief cet essai parti un
mail à ses cinq humains parce que
mouiller avec recette pour défendre les
maîtres fous des beats pour toi la dame
est tombée 6 sur torse et 7eme tour food
évite qui bien sûr qu'ils venaient
cruella d'ordre maintenant il peut je
trouve ça s'est tranquillement ouais je
pensais plutôt que effectivement qu'il
avait la carte pour tâches commerciales
a cassé quatre pour le cavalier
du coup la tête mantille avec mp3 bien
qu'elle valait points d'écart il faut
alors qu'en fait la corée c'est que
cette dame d un vide a préféré garder un
bon est ce que c'est ce qu'on va
pas assister à une première nul là
ni vous plaît du règlement par rapport
au nul est ce que tu arrêtes tu as les
éléments d'un nul c'est l'humain
c'est mieux baird ok c'est un match qui
va durer et qui va durer trois heures
donc
donc la venue et sia nul il ya 7 05
05 d'accord
ils ont le droit de faire annuler genre
à proposer quand ils veulent tous
arrière
après on lui on n'est pas là pour faire
du le salon mais mais oui oui a priori
on va
le q7 avant l'ère hu à la sas avance
tout y aura plus nul 1 1
peut-être
alors qu'on sait trop que l'on paye à
tous réfutent qui va arriver un fût il
faut hausse est alors bien ça dépend un
mandat plus large à jauger partir dans
tous les sens là mais
qu'avaient les béthouart sa
pression on sait que plus un drame de
temps et là bas le roi il va se cacher
ses seins le v6
3 6 3 et 5 c
wallace a sa part dans tous les sens ils
ont plus le temps alors il ya le lay et
il ya eu plus de rater un shoot party à
la fin quand vous voyez un ordinateur
ouais là ils sont redevenus ma ça nous a
rappelé des choses que l'on peut faire
régulièrement à ses fans dans
l'affolement il y avait un affolement
général
donc
donc qu'est 1-0 pour sa rigueur de ce
corps donc c'est un poulain ont été en
effet pour lui vanter de pousser sa
seconde et demie mais tu as eu ces
maliens bienvenus
on savait en fait on ne savait pas de
ceux qui répondent
pourtant la partie à semble-t-il été
parce que
bon c'est ça un serpent déjà en version
c'est sans plus attendre à 100 voix
c'est le fameux speech et squares y est
on est dans un autre registre
une ouverture plus professionnelle à la
confiance est tout blanc
c'est ce même cadre à n'y a pas eu ces
quatre voiliers qui ont ces deux étaient
incertains vais donc c'est quand même
bien bien différent y'a pas la pression
sans fin
il faut là encore les deux joueurs on
voit qui veut pas trop utiliser
de prépa théorique on est plutôt dans
des souliers c'est pas moi je pense
qu'il essaie de voir de deux voire plus
ce qui se passe en début de match et
après peut-être sortir
artillerie mai mais en fait je pense par
rapport aux deux joueurs annoncés lors
kimball blitz et je pense qu'ils
attendent tous les deux
la période de fin de partie sud et les
bullet par la différence
en tout cas je pense surtout sensible et
quand même censé être moins forte ce
match
mais bon coup les ouvertures sont un
petit peu
après je pense est normal mais bon moi
jamais bon on fait deux matchs de britz
comme ça est-ce que de masse du blitz
comme ça ça se prépare nous d ouverture
est-ce que tu
[Musique]
ce que j'avais je l'aï vu souvent par
exemple dans le premier sketch est ce
genre les matchs sur un haka mvl et du
one aka qu'ils préparaient une ligne qui
perd précisément sur genre lagerfeld
maxime et c'était sans arrêt la même
davantage vente l'indépendant prendront
pas part changement je pense qu'il ya
deux types de joueurs et là ce qui se
préparait ce qu'ils vivent un petit peu
harrach pour se faire plaisir tu voir
avec plusieurs systèmes
il ya différentes façons d'aborder ce
type de tournoi ce que je pense qu'ils
vont aussi comme de ludique du ludique
donc ça dépend des joueurs ça dépend des
joueurs là qui le font hyper
sérieusement et d'autres qui veulent
garder cet état d'esprit en qui peut
vite et de la sueur pézilla
et laure voir qu'il ya pas eu de support
de il n'y a pas de préparation théorique
à proprement parler on voit que ça joue
pas le joueur ou à venir la sarine n'ai
rien fait de d'extraordinaire et noir
après les artistes et pas t'es pas la
théorie de poids
en tout cas ni un crs qui nous a fait
c'est quand même pas très beau il se
retrouve à 4 isoler une pièce milliards
d'échangés
et un voile léger est faible cela fait
beaucoup pouvoir régler le blanc ou de
quelques coups doivent pas être très
satisfaits ou la cepal
ya pas y avoir ce qu'on voulait je suis
assez d'accord avec eux désolé mais bon
vous avez un milieu d'eux c'est quand
même assez triste en plus au classement
ce qui est des changes est donc la case
enfin pour improviser l'on va et c'est
souvent de jouer avec des cinq pour
essayer changer limite ça et à 109 15
ans un petit peu difficile ici deux des
cinq et donc larmes en russie et noir
d'un v6 de mettre une question des cinq
ans je pense avoir un cavalier des sacs
essayé de changer des pièces et devises
justement cette case dessin compacte
devant plus justement pousser d'options
donc le samsung
wave of war mais la problématique c'est
de gérer la structure d'opium c'est ça
et après pétrans être avant des idées là
de carli prat j'espère qu'avec 35 pour
un jeu sur le fiancé trois quarts alias
m marche aussi enlevé sur les pions
pendant
là malheureusement sur toutes vos le
cloud computing avec cavaliers à 5 et à
essayer de bloquer les cases blanches
avec d'amd 5 août à s'accuser cavaler
points 5 qui tu joues ton fiancé 3 c'est
vrai mais était possible en feintant oui
mais moi je pense que j'aurais dû
cavaler propose un possible mais
est-ce que ça plaît ton art cause ou pas
je ne sais bien à quoi compenser ces
gars là a validé en fait c'est qu'elle
regardait aller prendre le cinquième
rang des prend 2,5 savait que ça serait
un peu cavalier fiscale qui les passions
du roi donc c'est ok c'est pas si simple
que ça met en confiance quand même à
richard rapport est ce qui m
bloque un peu sexy que pendant
donc
on dira que ça marche aussi ce qu'il a
fait
il peut faire mais bon ça va quand même
pas qu'on donne ouais pour l'instant
sénia sai on peut dire qu'il est un peu
passé à côté de son début parce que
c'est pas très agressif et du coup c'est
une partie plutôt professionnel où elle
met blanc elle souffre d'entrée ce qui
est quand même assez rare pour des
joueurs de ce niveau là
parce que les perspectives manqué pour
les bleus emmenés en défense après il
peut quand même gagner en tenant tenante
eux dans sa position et d'ailleurs est
même fait une minute à l'apport une
quasi mort
après c'est aussi le bon camp qui ne
sera pas pour ce match pour ce type de
match c'est vrai que ça peut aller loin
il fut un petit peu pour faire plaisir
comme du lecteur
là je pense qu'il serait un peu trop
plaisir avec les blu ray ça s'est un peu
mal passé donc assis je pensais très
bien joué à l'as baisse inquiets
garde clairement la casse ces quatre
cavaliers et du coup les pions les pions
c3 et des quatre qui sont qui sont pas
moins qu'ils sont du coup assez faible
la finition
donc la seule vraie bonne pression
travail pour les voir ouais c'est clair
les blancs monts 4 ça reste du coup de
sang mais c'est vrai que les femmes un
ballon en cloche pour les problèmes en
version
wifi depuis quasiment acquis que lui tu
vois dans des avoirs qu'ils ont plus de
perspectives du coup il va essayer de
ouais je sais pas ce qui va essayer de
faire en tête d'un bois d'angers cas tu
vois on dit il va faire comment
commencer si bien faire et c'est
d'envoyer l'adversaire corner mal ça
c'est notre école les balles françaises
donc qu'elle valait procès pendant
qu'ils accusent un atout quand même mais
il dispense que celui d'alger quatre
vols avec fois au prince et il veut à
bien
et il veut compliquer la position donc
je pense qu'on fait c'est petit mais
bruyant très bien j'en pratique puisque
la force d'ouvrir
la brique m après neuf cents cavaliers à
5 des fois sur le pion aux injustices et
vis-à-vis un roi dame qui se souvenait
aussi d'un drap qui compensa mais bon
est-ce que ça va suffire et que mieux
demande attendue enfin savais que ça
rapporte quand même
ça maintenant la
nasa va être content des grosses
complications
non mais faut faire quelque chose quand
même à cannes noires essayez donc mais
il va prendre du temps et j'aime
beaucoup ce soit d'autre là il faut
réagir à un bel vis-à-vis à tout prix
mais il faut réagir alors comment tu as
le vis-à-vis de tout faire être sympa ce
que tu bouges et droit est ce que tu
veux faire quoi
[Musique]
vous couvrez le coin ça m'apparaît cette
norme avait contre attaqué avec un
batteur 5 c'est aussi gagner du temps
donc ça ça parait aussi intéressant
voilà f5 et s'ils jouaient d'art g6 peut
être très vite tout à fait à ce que je
pensais aussi des envies d âme et je
prends des techniques pour chaque jour
ok donc la dame prend des cas donc il
n'a pas peur du tout est ce un rapport
la réunion tu bluffes complètement et de
la mafia ici
et là et les plans s'enquit qui
s'offrait dans wanted and death and or
on va être joué à mon avis c'est pas net
voilà et du coup bah ils sécurisent
déjà placé à voir si je quand tu vois
taylor culture dont +1 le but d'empêcher
l'adversaire donc ça nous a fait
honorable à me faire ça moi j'aurais
fait je pense qu'on l'aurait touchée
on aurait tout serait pareil c'est moche
mais c'est comme ça
exactement exactement et elle ne voyait
voilà il faut pas il faut pas rentrer
dans l'axé des changes non plus quand
les meilleurs
vos matériels mêlant voir c'était un
échange de dames hyper mal à même de
bons qu en plus dont là ça s'y prêtait
bien leur rôle ce thème et madras qui va
s'engager il avait ses deux enfants
dessins au feutre
et bassac bien voyage c'est parce qu'en
fait j'avais des idées souvent quand tu
joue cavalier sur camaïeu 4 qui avait
des idées avec tourcoing tours tour
prend un cavalier sa fourchette en fait
tout le temps tu as un thème qui est qui
arrivait souvent et du coup bon là
j'attaque tout cas d'aï donc je te force
à prendre une décision immédiate d'un
grand dessein qu'être intermédiaire tf1
l'acteur aurait
lieu aussi vite et à tour est ce que je
peux faire toujours aux six pour tenir
le cavalier tout mois commencé leur dire
motivés point fr
est maintenant fort envoyé à 40h noir
mais j'ai quelques courses et si ce qui
ne devait défendre
cette vidéo jeux maison on se découvre à
la
14éme fc m cid oui
c'est ça
voilà donc le cavalier il est
complètement fermée
je pense que la partie l'interview c'est
un ian khama lis ici c'est une menace un
jour avoir quelques cases
jusqu'à dont je pense qu'il veut jouer à
5 eca vallée g6 ils ont certes un
cavalier est ce qu on n'empêche pas le
problème mais voilà trop si je tourne
les cours débutent
aujourd'hui je pensais pas qu'il allait
serment à faire même
après ça marche bien l'anti je sais
c'est la clé le roi est actif on a
besoin de vivre pour tous ceux qui ne
regardent que nous manquons de repères
la finale de cavaliers c'est que ça
marche quand les finales d'options
voilà donc comment je gagne la finale de
pions dont on doit le gagnant de la
firme de car a dit voilà l'histoire
alors on sait très bien qu'on a déjà
fini 6e position
en disant ça malheureusement ça marche
pas à chaque fois mais là il va il va
convertir les balles et f3 et la
projection un scat déjà
je vois pas comment il s'en sort aussi
servir de park avait laissé six en ce
moment il a fallu aller c'est quoi cette
manière on a raté un truc
très peur
mais en passant par leur côté
il fait une quinzaine quarantaine
contenait power et quel parti c'est la
première partie je crois personne exclue
cavaliers il a fait le tour des esprits
d'ivoire et elle était la même à il va
finir pour cavaler les six cavaliers
stadium
vous voyez ces jolies en option un port
qui a été avancé l'idée de
revenir parmi les grands axes de votre
côté alors qu'avec des deux ça couvre
effectivement mais c'est payant
dans le principe très passive donc on va
s'arrêter l'arrêté de l'enva dépanneur
idée quand il a donc avalé g2 maintenant
cavalier g6 raquette g2 je pense et on
n'a personne en amont à chaque fois ba
avait déjà manqué justement
parce qu'il prend un handicap car la pio
lesquels bromés trois ans c'est fatigant
mais encore des putschs ans pratique le
cavaly c'est que call of the dead le
cavalier acheter de la peine ouais mais
ça peut en pratique plus difficile
vu monter moins disposé 6 et sinon même
hyper mittal à deux manches chacun bon
alors on gagne et vraisemblablement
de la c1 arkema est convenablement
ses lacets pour personne les bancs les
deux pions luxe car l'équipe ne peut
s'appliquer que sur un pion heureusement
d'affaires bien attention à son arrivée
noir il va pas à temps avance et ses
deux pions on peut imaginer ce à ses
fans je vois bien comme ça
passe moins passera si on veut gagner en
place bien revoir et puis après on
pousse les pions en bloc
gamin vous prend bien se montrer ses
seins et damery hier
il très fort à ceux des matches déjà ces
bonnes techniques parce que bon on se
faire arnaquer il prend son temps mais
aucun aucune chance il
va finir par faire masser intervenir
juste raquette ou fait bloc a envoyé 10
9 points les pions il les accompagne en
blanc qui sait bien jouer comme tu dis
c'est pas là il a pris son temps
à l'étranger 5
mai à saint pierre de rome du g3
alors pourquoi est elle a dû manquer
beaucoup de temps un pour gagner au
final je me demande souvent les patients
atteints supra en plus
ces casses pieds à gagner
l'opposition
ça vient ça vient il faut pas oublier le
temps aussi en oublie ça parce que nous
on commence c'est facile on veut pas
tomber mais les deux joueurs à chaque
roue et peuvent oublier la pendule sur
un coup c'est pour ça qu'ils se branyan
sarine il sait que ça peut décoller 1 ça
y est
le cavaliere 3 la fourchette qui fait
mal à ses fans et essaye bien de la
mayenne devions je fais un petit
changement dans ce que alors au niveau
du vieux volets tchad au niveau du micro
il tient le baseball
qui apparemment est trop bas il y en eut
fait entendre à ses fans est-ce que ça
va mieux ici
je peux continuer à parler et merci à
mme fatou pour sa petite remarque
alors je vais changer la vitesse
d'animation ainsi
ça ira mieux pour être moi je joue
généralement quand je quand je joue sans
cesse comme je suis pas d'en jouer dans
l'egypte en direct et du coup j'avais
pas je n'avais pas du tout configurer la
vitesse
des pièces
est barbare voir l'histoire du
saut
on vient de me le dire par sms qui avait
un petit problème de sont apparemment
que tu vois
est-ce que ça va me du mot son union
alors nous le dire maintenant vous êtes
vous aimez testeurs
on avait une petite espagnole là
pour le moment et ça va être beaucoup
plus agréable à jouer pour richard
importe cette partie à mon avis
puisqu'on a la bonne structure de pion
dans le tandem dame cavaliers
ce
n'est pas
le moins si je peux régler mon propre
micro et
le descends
je sais pas si ça va aider le stéphanois
je peux faire ça aussi
non je vais pas jouer aux toilettes
est-ce que ça va mais où est ce qu'on
voit sur peral
[Musique]
je suis quasiment plus bas normalement
mais bon apparemment micro fonctionne
bien bonne nouvelle à ce niveau là
alors est ce que c'est bon
ok je vois on n'y arrive pas
ok là la bonne méthode manuelle ses fans
c'est ça c'est ça
alors
donc du coup dans ce match on est à un
partout
donc exact
j'arrive avec un tir plus pour richard
laporte dans cette troisième partie à
mon avis en pratique cette plus agréable
puisque on voit car au niveau structure
de pions donc ça c'est l'espagnol des
changes donc à noter que dans l'espace
des chances
finale sont généralement pas très bonnes
pour mémoire
ouvriers en fait que si on échange
toutes les pièces en fait de l'échiquier
mais quand il te reste qu'avec les rois
et les pions en fait cette place a
permis pour l'année pour les voir parce
que j'ai j'ai de ce cousinage 4 contre 3
et le 4 contre eux ne passent jamais et
d'autres tg4 gens ici votre 3 est en
fait c'est un peu comme si on avait
besoin de plus en finale en finale
depuis un quai oui tout à fait c'est
exactement cela l'explication
baptisons joue un autre ordre de coupe
d'espagne des choses mais ils sont
retombés dans la structure comme tu le
soulignes de l'espagne des changes
stéphane et et du coup on préfère en
plus le tandem dame cavaliers plus
complémentaires sur les deux couleurs de
cases et du coup c'est une position qui
semble plus agréable pour les blancs
mais la dame noire et plus dynamique
plus plus actif que la dame blanche du
coup il ya un peu de pression pas même
les pièces noires faut faire cette
pression notamment sur l'avion ces deux
avec cavalli qui est cloué maintenant
lancé trois
lettres qu'on peut imaginer une solution
passait assez dynamique avec f5 parce
que les les noirs doivent ouvrir le feu
de cave blanche doit baisser le
valoriser
bon assez basse a été jouée a été jouée
par sylvie dans les faubourgs et on
connaît trois qui étaient peut-être que
président à bord
ça c'est normal le foot est malheureux
de gaz vous pouvez rien à faire acte et
après un super s'apparenterait c'est ça
qui est un petit peu quand même
en plus ils ils ouvrent tout à ce coup
de pions les coûts de pioncer ce cas
plus importants et chaque convoi qui
loue la tour et il fait vivre les pièces
en fait donc sa délivre le fou 1,6 et la
tour et fit sur le pion faible au rêve
de pas fait mal et j'ai aussi des ide
éventuellement avec du f4f crois qu'il
faut pas négliger aussi
d'un problème de
ces jeux lisa
johnny c'est là le point 4 échecs
découverte il se rapporte il a oublié
c'est sûr on peut le dire il a oublié la
petite tactique elle est belle celle là
est la belle découverte je pense que
tout le monde sera garé en tout cas vu
la vitesse à laquelle ça joue ça c'est
sympa quand même l'asec l'instant sur un
an on s'attendait pas moi j'aurais joué
quatre personnes je
vois ouais j'ai pas vu non plus
c'est d'ailleurs mon rédac il a quand
même raté richard rapporte donc ouais
c'est pas si facile c'est pas si l'on
est difficile en partie le très rapide
cette finale maintenant comment on
disait non on disait pas ça c'est pas
notre époque savons disait que c'était
bien pour les blancs et maintenant c'est
passé est vraiment mauvais pour les
blancs me jean piot de moins que lille
va se sentir
un
vieux fou en plus ouais ça c'est une
finale théoriquement gagnait on sait
avec le régler 2 l on préfère avoir le
fou maintenant on va pouvoir admirer la
technique et on faire confiance à un
énième série donc il ya plein de petites
rougeurs peut-être même un héros aura
trois ça peut être une idée et si lui
aussi de jouer des coups comme des fois
même des fous j'ai deux pourraient
éprouver au cash 4 et dernier droit sur
les deux branches genre
jet4you nra moi qui avais plus fort que
cavaye ans position qui peut dominer le
guerrier c'est facilement
la paix
c'est donc on voit centralisation des
rois ouais le gie manor qui l'a bien
rangée 4 oui
mais tu vois jean sirois f5 par exemple
cavalière 4 pour dire eh bah y aurait
comme fouet à cette fête qui prend
toutes les cartes du cavalier les gars
mais qui pourra plus du tout a bougé sur
ses talonnades là on atteint but a été
exaucé à la vallasse ça je voulais le
montrer et du coup le fou d'un actif de
même clairement le cavalier sur cavalli
les troyens v6 normalement c'est m6 et 4
mai super sympa et
la france b si ce doit être le coup
parce que sur sur cavalli détroit ces
cas turc avait laissé cinq attaques
desserte et
donc à sakhir arrangements des frais
fixes et sur nord maintenant
ouais on rapporte qu'il s'est pris une
petite tactique toujours malheureux
morin qui a nui à la sarine
convertissent ah ouais sa position alors
géographe tic tac tic tac tic au bout de
80 pouces et devoirs
elle a préféré ne pas prendre
c'est ça qui est dommage l'adresse mac
ou justice fédérale a pas mal c'est
quand même beau parce qu'il a absorbé y
est pour mettre tous les pions blanc sur
blanc et maintenant le fou ça arrive
c'est un vrai que pour idée de de pêcher
tous les pions blancs comme stéphane
propose avec foubert et du coup là c'est
vraiment embêtant de trois cépages ou et
vous met ainsi facilement si facile
parce qu'avec le guerrier après je peux
jouer cavalier a je crois sur oise 5 est
embêté un petit peu
au une classe est intéressant parce que
les finales alors moi je pense que je
mange tempo qu'en jouant vite ce qui
fait forcément vous partons plus mais
mais il faut réussir à passer leurs
prisons apprendra le 6 on sauve nra 4 tu
passes jamais je pense alors ces signes
à ses rennes joue un tout petit peu vite
c'est quand cela parce qu'il est riche
mais bon il a peut-être oublié cavaliers
le quartier une sorte de contrepoint de
tactique
encore heureux 5 1 et je pense qu'avec
ces trois par contre pour nous défendre
at the attack et bien parce que roy 5 av
à l'étranger ça mange à deux et je mange
peu étroit et je pense ça va être trop
dur
donc je pense dans le pire des cas il
veut juste jouer avoir
re 5 khz avec 7,3 food où j'ai essayé de
tenir celle là
je pense en pratique un
calcul vous prend 1 4 mois il doit
calculer frankart vérifier pascal et
histoire de coups de réserve pour pour
regagner l'opposition je pense ne sert à
rien parce qu'en fait le même
imaginons même sur un fou prendre eux
aussi ce genre à quatre ses six mètres
assez sage et plus j'ai plus de coups de
réserve on m'a dit il faudrait que je
veux voir où 15.3 et il manque un peu de
réserve sa cellule et petit tempo de
réserve ce que c'est simple c'est le
petit coup de pions qui vous permette
d'inverser une opposition et de dribbles
et le roi adverse quand il se décale là
on va on va se faire coincer ça passe
pas
donc
lorsqu'on aura un coût de réserve avec
1,4 en plus soit fait
et ce qu'ils voient des blancs pourrait
peut-être jouer à trois breaks
pour certains jours le traquenard et
finale d'options et
3e set a été jouée voir la grosse
réflexion quand je recettes et cette
fois on va jouer très vite
il s'est fait bouffer son temps en plus
fort
voyez un même dans les parties de très
haut niveau sous pression du temps voit
ya des petits drames il y avait eu un
premier dame dans un sens prise de
clichés rapporte avait raté hélas un
brin de cavaliers aux cartes ça a été
aussi un coup dur la c6 et mais la loi
qu'on avait quand même travailler
qu'avec des quatre
ans était là mais difficile à passer
leurs baskets comment tu le risque de
mort
tu penses quoi toi tu progresses
vous avez envie de le re 5 à chaque fois
ok mais
perd manière at banyan au courant
et le fameux à quatre
et on a va falloir expliquer mon conte
des trois moines en fait vous pouvez
investir je pense à
il aura alors encore
assez indécis à chaque fois relais
dans la grosse défense gamme de données
chaque rapport un grosse
grosse défense c'est plus ou qui avaient
leurs couteaux ils risquent ils ont des
ressources des deux côtés un cd cd
monstre en voie
sachant qu'il ya eu un un coup qui a été
jouée à vraiment de manière hyper lente
c'est le 40e coup quoi il se planque est
envoyée aux quatre là ce que j'ai
presque deux minutes le nid à sarine
dommage qu'il n'ai pas réfléchi avant et
c'est toujours plus facile de
commentaires que de vivre ça on sait
bien mais vouloir qu'on a fait une
bêtise mais c'est trop tard c'est un
bouc il a dû voir mais qu'il a dû un peu
zappé en fait je pense que je me suis
dit croyez pas qu'on n'y croyait pas
être vous manque et j'ai donc du sport
et il a un peu négligé je pense le
secoue alors que ça va être le
répliquant la pendule
dépôt la caroline qui ont ils fait
confiance quand je pense qu'il
faille on le calcule son moment je
comprends que la journée pareille
et sa nouvelle partie on a droit un
double film très tôt avec les bleus en
preuve que les joueurs ne sont pas
vraiment dans un combat théorique un
temps ça
après après chez les indiens en général
soit google très grande la sarine
je vois que ça vous énorme en d3 ou
partir ce type de position est
d'ailleurs j'ai entendu je pense que
c'était
sus des noms s'appelait
j'oubliais clandestins indiens la main
de jacky à
26,30 maintenant un jeune de 21 ans va
falloir et l'aï battu il est bête je
crois shirov dans la partie d'un grand
drapeau français libres alta et en fait
ils passent grands maîtres avec ce lien
n'avait plus qu'un seul parti à ravine
arabinda alors il ya tellement je t'aime
marin et un mot à ravine
avant la partie dont il parle avec
ramesh l'entraîneur a bien évidement de
bondoukou tard paris quoi pour prendre
parti contre sociologue il dit bah en
fait je sais que si je joue le 4ème
stylet pour défoncer sur n'est rien du
coup belges ab3 et plus beau jeu
d'échecs quoi et le mec enfin le gamin
il avait 13 ans quoi tu vas 13 ans à
réty moi je mets trois jours des chèques
personnels l'ouverture et il a défoncé
sur
rien c'est relatif quand il dit ça c'est
rien à part avoir un coût m hyper
expérimentait lequel shirov bref c'est
toute proportion gardée mais il se rend
compte effectivement il prend du recul
sur les choses et se dit qu'il est plus
faible dans un secteur du jeu donc il
serait adapté au foot en fait comme au
foot quand on fait une bonne on est un
bon système en place moi c'est pareil il
faut voir ses forces et ses faiblesses
et et mettre le système en place et nos
principaux
projets prend h4 ça donnait envie toi
stéphane moi j'aurais jamais fait ça
comme ça s'agite au
qu'est ce que c'est que cette horreur
mais bon bah s'il la joue et c'est que
les plus fins non je prendrai une pause
du mois j'ai du mal à comprendre ce qui
se passe a provoqué au fait soudain pour
les 4 je prends des signes sont
accomplis oui le chemin quand tout
roule en jouant juste pour pour personne
c'est la structure je pense moi ça n'a
l'air logica france qui fera le 5 cancan
des sessions adhérents ne nous laissera
plus en prise
d'un quota de même directement si on
pense pas descendre de fuchs bouffe
alors je ne vois pourquoi cette
question-là fatou
mai mais c'est vrai que les indiens en
fait
ils jouent beaucoup en fait sans théorie
est généralement bas pierre il appelle
la théorie plus tard en fait sont pas
comme nous tous serons encore en europe
notamment en france à travailler
l'ouverture des cons on commence un vtt
dans un club d'échecs
là c'est l'inversé
[Musique]
après pour voir quand même que
effectivement les joueurs alliant dont
tu parles ils ont quand même des
prérequis théorique qui sont pas nulles
le coin c'est à dire que ils ont la
théorie elles restent ils actionnent sur
le reste mais sur la théorie zoo quand
même je me rappelle que j'ai achevé ni à
sérigne quand ils étaient plus jeunes de
11 ans est bien fait une grosse prépare
un coup à vidéo après par rapport aux
meilleurs mondiaux tu as raison c'est
pas possible qu'ils soient qu'ils soient
compétitifs parce que ils sont trop
jeunes mais franchement parfois il reste
quand même il resterait travaillons donc
en fait ils travaillent tous les
secteurs de jeu ils sont très complets
surtout c'est pour ça qu'ils viennent
simon sitôt
en tout cas je pense que je dépose
ses
magnifiques voilà c'est manuel il meurt
dans race
alors s'éprend des 5 vous ça donne plus
sur un petit peu il va compliquer le cas
mais la 4e arrivés à baba là c'est le
drame
kim et coup je regarde kayak gars comme
tom tu as dit c'est hyper complexe
quel enfer
misola content que mes deux mains parce
qu'ils se donnent coup pour coup ouais
dans sa série j'avais pas regardé sa
formule est à 4 minutes quoi
tu vas jorge arce a rien n'a rien à
[ __ ] à 5 mais prend 1,5
je ne mens jamais ils font tous les
mini mieux de dépenser près
comment cela s'est terminé 3e 67.6 h
théâtre et devient un problème
qu'on descend intérêts en décembre soit
fan ou les classes mais c'est aussi un
problème aussi et beaucoup de coups
candidats en fait la grève lancé ça mais
il va y arriver à prendre un peu de
temps mais quatre points améliorer
de façon qu'il est plus avantageux pour
les pour les noirs sont quand même pas
ce qu'il en ressort que le cavalier qui
par les vents et scat le roi blanc qui a
recouvert c'est quand même plus facile
pour les noirs
en pratique un jeu par là on en oublie
trop vite et c'est exactement ça mais en
fait ouais une fois que vous prendrez
saccagé concrètement qu'est ce qu'on
fait à gagnoa je suis le roi se cache au
rachat
la toile chercher avec des boyaux
tourcoing v6 qui peut arriver
mais leur horizon oui c'est ça comme il
ya chez mac pour j'ai un bon c c'est
plus facile quoi ça c'est concret que
cette position
on sait que l'on rende
que j'aime beaucoup le coût de
l'ordinateur
[Musique]
ok de quatre vingts logique hein c'est
vous le redire
les quatre places et apprends des cinq
faux 5 qui arrive aussi à tour ailleurs
je pense que on s'en fout un peu
notre question quand la torah il y aura
d'un point et après le roi noir sur 15
ans et 4 mois on va être traitée faire
l'annoncé qualité essentielle c'est dur
à prendre quand même
après un petit d'amd 4 cette croissance
est difficile à jouer deux fois en d5
est monstrueux l'acteur qui va taper g6
ça m'a l'air un petit peu difficile de
faire comprendre aux élèves sympa
vincent
est ce qu'il a un autre coup en fait
s'il a pas d'autre qu il va peut-être
s'y engager mais ça s'arrête à
contrecoeur
parce qu'après il ya plus d'un taxi fait
ça il aura plus au foot 15 noir pour
attaquer à bagua noir non mais là il est
vraiment hyper mal car seconde à la
pendule contre 3,20 ça prouve que l
agrandir qui se fait s'ils considèrent
qu'il est vraiment foutu je pense qu'il
faut manger at war
sinon bah hockey
la puce et 6 % par mois
c'est à gaz et la vida il a énormément
souffert dans cette partie ouais c'est
mais le rythme aussi s'était passé car
c'est quand même monstrueux en enchaîner
les parties comme ça ça n'a l'air de
rien alors des fois on peut le faire
pour sa musique je recherche ask.com
mais c'est vrai que là il ya un match en
jeu du coup il faut garder un niveau de
constance important et franchement c'est
vraiment pas facile et on voit que la
riche et raconte dans cette partie là il
a vraiment été dominés sur l'échiquier
et autant sur thoune est clairement
c'est vraiment s'en est pris
mais tu vois ces solutions de fin cette
petite position je pense que que ça rime
et du gémissement sa vie quand tu vois
les b 3e position je pense qu'il a dû
été revisitée
elle vraiment bien ouais c'est pas moi
qui joue quoi augurer d'un matériel
d'avant sans vous voyez tous et du coup
il va s est calmé la poésie et tout
reprend 1,4 soit sur la
crise prises
je crois qu'il a il essaie de faire un
petit baroud d'honneur attendait d'eux
je ne comprends pas ce qu'il a voulu
faire
il a dû se tromper mais bon après c'est
juste qu'ils étaient suppression du
temps et que voilà
donc les gammes pour le format en fait
donc je vous rappelle
qu'est-ce qu'on en fait impose un style
des plus cinglé toutes les armes et fret
entre un petit bac les facs qui
consistait donc
je tiens debout derrière
c'est chez moi c'est bon j'ai entendu
que les convois passant pose donc le
wildfire s'est arrêtée on assimile de
pose donc je vous mettre la petite la
petite pub de jazz comme et on se
retrouve dix estime illégale dont quatre
de suite à la tout de suite
[Musique]
nous sommes de retour les amis on a
perdu votre a perdu du coup kevin osei
on a ramé jeu je suis là pour l'instant
stéphane roussin s'est humblement tôt en
seconde
et voilà les bienvenus re salut à tous
alors oui nous pouvons repartir sur un
élève sur celui là parce qu'il n'a pas
les moyens il faut pas les câbles
alors le droit à un des milieux ou de
perdre 5 pouces et qui a donc ça la
partie du fou incessamment on va
exactement
donc en fait alors le guetteur fous ces
quatre ça peut être un sou en fait qu'on
veut éviter tout ce qui est ouverture
comme petrov
avec quatre cinq cavaliers trois
cavaliers les six
bien d'autres idées remet à l'avancé oui
par exemple at rapidement ce qui n'a pas
été atteint dans cette partie
alors déjà c'est assez intéressant pour
le coup
ce qui a été jouée par par les blancs
qui sacrifie dès le début août a vu ses
fins d'invasion potentiellement cette
fois comme un gambit à
une seule vitesse donc avaler pour ces
trois y investit en août dames 1 qui a
attaqué le 5 essais 3 owen
qui veux juste garder brison n'diaye ac
en attendant pour les membres
et depuis on sent qu'il veut être une
cible bien
voilà c'est déjà un sacré lors des deux
tours un pied on a position qui est un
petit peu meilleur
tour un quart des extraits ya encore des
amis des deux documents et cinq étaient
perdus
moi j'aime bien les blancs dans cette
position j'aime bien le foot comme ces
cas là c'est les casques blancs si si il
ya un petit problème sur aussi plus
riches rapporte connaissent la position
ouais donc là on est au 10e coup
je réponds à 30 secondes à la pendule
très bon depuis son attaque je pense
qu'il est plus ou moins encore dans ce
sens et connaître ouverture
à une grosse pression
ça se passe même promis un crs
il aime aussi du camel épreuve celle qui
pourrait arriver un défend d'être que
c'était mains italiennes 1 qu'il allait
prendre l'exact chèque
ça c'est sympa a montré à tout le monde
l'étude mf3 à prendre avec trois échecs
avec un cavalier et le roi évolution
rouge pour le faire
voilà on le voit moins souvent à
notre époque de dinosaures ça existait
bien mais maintenant les gens se font
assez au courant je l'envoie de moins en
mois sauf en inde de ces styles de ces
petits trucs là était à ce niveau là il
ya juste dix ans en israël
alors qu'elle essayait faussement donc
opté clairement le problème fait avaler
pour le 6 il ya de la terre de foot et
aussi diverses branches et mais on peut
aussi continuer avec un grammage strike
ou tombeur pour la grenouille hyper
intéressant ici candidats
des deux aussi être peinard peut-être un
lampion c3 toujours en l'air si c'est
toujours bien gelé par le programme et
quatre ans qu'il marchait normalement
demain c'est le coup le plus concret
pour pour mettre de la pression la calle
français 3 est vraiment gore ce que ça
donne ça n'atteint que même pour l'adar
sur les cases blanches avec damas trois
et il peut piquer un quartier précis
sous le coup de 15 morts donc c'est
vraiment très malin
et c'est dur déjà premier le sarine
d'ailleurs ça se vaut autant
la vie depuis le départ que celui qui a
le plus de temps maîtrise totalement
imposition généralement celui qui
consomme du temps il n'est pas à l'aise
avec sa position tout à l'heure c'était
l'effet inverse signal sarine dominer
totalement et avec beaucoup plus de
temps et
donc c'est vraiment compliqué
là j'ai pas touché le micro à l'heure
c'était
je veux dire je vais
l'ambiance il faudrait équilibré mais
j'en ai touché un
nerf coincé avec moi parce que sinon je
ferais sans précédent et est
ok
alors c'était ok
ouais et puis moi j'aime bien sûr pas de
créer mon micro
lança dans la taule je n'ai pas lu m
alors donc il ya quelques mois s'était
joué voilà
dégommer la structure noir et
franchement c'est c'est propre c'est que
l'or bondisse mais très agréable pour
les blancs ils vont vraisemblablement
une double haie sur la colonne ne par
exemple ce serait logique de 6,5 qui
sont à terme
50 centimes à la partie voire d'avoir
aussi un contre mais mesdames la culture
de la même
voix la pieve 3 des fractures et des
pions et maintenant il va pouvoir
s'occuper des des mauvais pour eux voilà
l'objectif
de me dresse plus fort donc l une des
plus voir un réseau sûr alors je suis
c'est un petit peu
alors tu me dire je peux nombre des ses
larmes et j'ai baissé
alors du coup 1 6
les débris sur veulent s'emparer de ce
fou donc surtout à natura et 5ème année
à 5 j'imagine
qu'elle avait encore 85e on n'a
peut-être pas forcément envie donner
plus de 5
est-ce qu'on pourrait cette fois on
ressent comme un jour faudra y aller
1-3 chasser un bon coup de bleach je
trouve pas ce que tu en penses ses fans
mais j'aime bien ce genre de coup on
passe prendre une petite [ __ ] rival
aux morts
lorsque vous avez aussi dans les temps
et villages 3d fois donc wash
enseignants et des villageois
le grenat éventuellement moi
j'ai envie de lui enlever ses jantes
cavaliers là
il fait peur
sur la base de contrats faire attention
si cette fois 4 en l'air aussi
évidemment je pense que sur tout point à
4,4 production
voilà
et maintenant on a plus qu'à doubler
vous doublez soit
sur la colonne tour 4 qu'on ne voit
aucun moment
c'est pareil ça paraît vraiment beaucoup
plus facile à jouer ses fans maintenant
pour me dire des pleins mais c'est en
train de mal tourner le besoin a ouvert
sa saison par gore c'est de l'art
classique humainement il peut jouer
facile est pressurisé avec toutes ces
pièces le plus strict
on pourrait même imaginer qu'ils trient
france
ses torts
bon et puis bien sûr on peut rappeler
que c'est la journée de pause repas du
monde en sac on ne va pas trop mal et
c'est la pause c'est pour ça qu'il ya
cet événement c'est
simple non musulmans et en même temps je
m'en sens parce que quand même dès
[Musique]
que j'ai regardé à jour que les journées
droit pour la cij dis pas de bêtises les
one oui oui c'est sûr en face les
contrats tu vois ça doit être compliqué
à gérer la planification mari à brugg
pour moi ben si aigu comme elle tente le
grand tunis en
ouest est passé pour pour cela je pense
que c'est c'est vraiment compliqué et
cela donnera les messieurs c'est
seulement en ce moment de plus juste une
image tout cas les avants avant la fin
de l'année
et il arrive cependant se plaint du
monde il ya quand même pas mal de
joueurs de tout premier plan qui sont
disponibles sauf ceux qui font peut-être
partie des teams mais
bon voilà le travail est bien fait
toujours parler par les blancs et
l'avantagé en train de croître un petit
peu différents avantages tout à l'heure
c'est l'oreille sur les pions maintenant
c'est un bon indice il a été converti en
davantage d'activités
avec une septième ronde des kings qui
est prise
une grosse partie de richard appartement
celle là pour mort est sévère ouais
c'est une dizaine de gamins
au fond
tout ce qu'elle perde ainsi à tenir et
finalement vous débarquez dans l'excès
c'est l'art c'est voler sur un avantage
mans
mais
attention car ils comptent 3 revient
voir robben 17
non madame 17 march 26 1 petite dame 2
pour
regardez
qui ont dépassé en l'air encore coincés
à nax accélérait envoyée il ya moins
d'une minute chacun donc là ça peut être
un petit peu n'importe quoi
on a beau auteur vous étiez
donc les dames d2 c'est sûr que c'est
plus agréable pour les blancs mêlés la
tour noire au travail pénible donc ça
peut être facile ni pas là il va se
doubler maintenant à gué droit summa
point de vue d'abaisser d'un v6 mu pour
nous trop de
éventuellement
du coup ça reste assez indécis puisque
j'ai pas mon groupe enfin j'ai un film
plus mais il n'est pas encore valorisé
si j'ai pas en option passé
mais d'ailleurs il il a l'air de vouloir
qui appelait
bien vu ces 5
c en v tendresse que ce que richard
raconte qu'ils avaient fait une super
partie va gagner c'est plus sûr
ça vient vite à un stéphane dans ce
money time y est ce
parce qu'il a occupées par des cap d'un
point il répétait le tourer
la d3 je commençais à m'intéresser à
essayer de bloquer avec prise dam des
caps lock il est hors de question de
manger mais trois directement six coups
simples rebloqué le pion passé et c'est
hier que de pousser notre culture avec
des cales p3
comme ces cartes météo de demain soir on
s'est mis perchoir ouais d'un des quatre
combattants des brigades et sur un
échange en sorte
d'accélérer ainsi les gens même les plus
grands champs est ok lâche pas qu'un des
joueurs devraient gagner le gros lot
patience est comme ça et ça c'est voilà
avec sa rage de joueurs s'arrange pour
eux qui à une répétition on va dire donc
bien plus graves de rester véniard super
party on voyait très bien jusqu'à
présent être critères qualitatifs ouais
on voit que les deux joueurs en cas de
grosses ressources à 3,5 qui avait une
mission
très très difficile a réussi à maintenir
c'est vraiment la colline
donc décadente il refait tout à l'heure
le 4 l et es rapports qui sont au centre
réagi au sens avec des seins donc
d'abord il ya mené ces gammes et leurs
quatre enfants dès 6 ans c'est la
différence parce qu'ils savent qu'ils
s'adaptent bien voilà
bon pour l'instant à chaque fois on
préfère un petit peu la position
des marées noires
il ya 900 wagner pièces plus active donc
son ouverture c'est l'adoption qui est
aux anges bien je pense pas ta de non
non c'est pas un match comme ça kevin
comment s'appelle par avance et la
couverture blanche et orange ont
redoublé en quatorze nouvelles
c
c'est pas d'ouverture très référencé
cdu-verts plus atypique donc
en théorie un
bon sens les pièces
oui on diffère incombera après
à haut niveau maintenant avec les pièces
blanches il essaie quand même de prendre
avantage
lassé des joueurs à très très haut
niveau mais en partie lente en tout cas
ils essaient normalement on voit bien
d'ailleurs dans la partie des affaires
du monde il ya vraiment une volonté pour
les blancs d'obtenir un petit plus du
blois ce juste on sort les pièces et et
on joue aux échecs dames à l'adducteur
et pas forcément aussi le moment de
sortir les gros ce qui n'est pas pour un
tribunal il ya il ya de l'argent à
gagner un derby bien évidemment mais
après
sortir des grosses prépare en ce moment
là c'est un petit peu inutile je pense
en complètement non c'est
j'ai exactement la même logique c'est à
dire que voilà enfin on va pas brillé
ces armes pour eux qui travaillent
énormément quoi même les ouvertures
donc on a grillé leur temps de travail
sur sur un blitz comme tu vas dire
et la partie très positionnelle c'est
pas la partie la plus rigolote qu'on a
vu jusqu'à présent
ok donc moi j'aime beaucoup les noirs ce
gros centres la contractent des simples
pour voyage est pour de la casse des 5
pour le cavalier pour le fou même
dessous des 5 août doit arriver et
changer les bras un espace ce qui est
intéressant c'est qu'en donne le son
comme ça on voit que il ya un ami d'amar
tou v2 pour provoquer un trou de pions
disloquer les centres et venir l'attaqué
dans un second temps
les cases et du coup il ya des cas et c4
et c5 woerth les pièces blanches ont
commencé à trouver des cases pour pour
venir chatouiller
chatouiller les noirs y avoir aussi
qu'avec des cadres d'un jeu aussi la
casse c'est 3-1 qu'est-ce que cela moi
j'aime bien les coudes et 5 pour
aujourd'hui tout cas cela veut dire et
le roi noir est l'endroit où l'engin et
après quelle vallée des saints car elle
sera par exemple clairement une idée
pour pour
embêter un peu les blancs qui avaient
lancé trois tours s'est vite comme ça ça
peut être pas mal
vincennes ce n'est là cavalier à bias et
william il ya des risques à le four b3
c'est à dire qu'on prend des deux époux
b3 si je perds four quelque part
si je fais pouvait cacher en fut les
deux fois je perdais pas la dernière
donc je vais le montrer donc si nous le
voulons rang des six par exemple faut
prendre bientôt reprendre il a retrouvé
trois avec un people sur le clavier à 4
qui serait cloué temps normal un rayon
laser damas aldama n'était pas assez
chaud parce que
il ya le problème de twente aussi qui
arrivent
il va être bien en médecine sait rien on
gérait tout ça c'est de la torah but
c'est quand même assez fort y'a pas toi
2 lequel ne peut pas bouger et bien joué
je vois bien un petit prono tour à 8
ouais mais je veux pas trop en fait de
défense notamment
défendu des fois en fait
c'est perdu 1
oui c'est la première partie ça se passe
si mal parce que là ça va être une pièce
alors est ce qu'il ya une magouille d'un
cran à 4 tours c'est 8
mais même dans le canton c'est ok je
trouvais fuite aura ça marche pas et il
faut prendre cavaler vent et je vois pas
trop ce qui se passe
à neuf pour cabaye est improbable
aujourd'hui la vente comprend je peux
faire d'un point à 3
ok mais fou prend à 3 tu fais
ou prend 1,3 à penser 8 non j'ai mal
calculé je sais pas vrai salaire est ça
la tour est toujours en prison s'est
mise puisque
voilà ma tête ça il est allé directement
peut-être c'est plus simple parce que du
coup tu lien mais il apprend à 4 pour
ses huit titres au point fixe oued
parfois ça marchait
l'apprend accroît sa marche aux qu'il y
avait tour à 86,8 en l'air si tu veux
quand tu repreneur aura trois fois elle
fit comme s'il n'y a pas de débat tu as
vu il a tué notre meilleur visage humain
c'est pas non là on voit quand même la
classe
12e avec le marché rapport à qui donne 0
contre je et ben c'est fou quand elle
fut de cavaler points avaient fusé en
fait le cavalier perdu de ce que
véhicule loué et il n'est pas défendable
si je met à tourner un vieux fou tu as
tu as un galet sur le canal donc
il n'ya pas de là ya pas de points mais
pas tours de magie ouais et il coupe
tout contrôleur et il garde la menace la
menace qui est plus commune a
cependant il reste encore à ivandry un
corner puis zut
dans cette période
oui c'est la première période d'une
heure et demie en fagne plus à aures
grâce à rémy après on aura une heure
quand ce que vous montrez un après on
aura on aura une heure de trois coups
sport et ainsi qu'une demi heure de
budget
donc donc les dames angers le cavalier
en gav est dans une pièce de plus c'est
encore un plombier mais ce qu'on vaut la
cci
va tomber dallaire deux reprises de se
faire dérober
4g conjugue avec moi là on glissait
derrière
le dessin et qui réalise et sait-on
maman je te fais ton dessin comme sa
cavale et ses trois victoires en paca
dans ces trois
associations ya pas qu il est aussi le
monsieur duquenne avec mon dessin qui va
arriver je pense grâce à revendre
aussitôt abandonné je pense à la broche
métier mais je sais pas tu pense qu'il
va abandonner ouais il va en fait un
petit peu ça dépend parce que je pense
que ça arrive
il qu'elles m'ont avoir de meilleurs
verra pour les chèques
et du coup la cadence ou bien moins fort
ce serait normalement le simplisme art
parce que c'est là on confie un peu plus
c'est compliqué et peut-être que du coup
ça il n'y peut penser qu'il urine un peu
de temps pour essayer de
six moins de particules en simplisme et
après essayer de marquer des parfums
vous marquez de points en transition je
pense que la de pavant donné je pensais
pas bêtes ne soient pas
au niveau du match il a essayé de faire
durer la partie
pour
pour faire le moins de parti possible en
simple messieurs
entame stratégiste moyens d'aider des
weppes et au delà du sort pour moins
gore pas encore ar cette position ce qui
se passe des fois des trucs bizarres
dans cosi manquait une pièce de plus
c'est beaucoup mais bon
pour faire un petit peu gaffe enfin le
temps en temps ils ont eu 1000 chacun
ne pourra jouer tout à fait un pot à ces
rapports n'ont eu une bonne surprise
mais loin pour l'instant
on n'a pas trop marché la stratégie du
double fait enquêter pour l'instant
la première commission enfin celle
d'avant envoyé une dépression impression
celle d'avant dans cette dame ans il a
l'espoir celle là n'ont malheureusement
pas être dès l'ouverture en fait ça a
déconné
donc ce n'est pas l'amélioration des
tresses ans dans cette position il n'y a
pas trop le choix
d'un rapport qui va encore une fois
prendre son temps pour venir aucun
contre eux bon du coup les api d'armes
quand même donc déjà un mieux contre
jusqu'à
jambes a commandé un blanc pourrait
vraiment un maquis et les forêts si
on n'agit je vois pas beaucoup moins de
faire un nom il attend puis je dis que
c'est un petit peu difficile à prouver
et un mois et le planche en fait
impression d angers c'est vrai que c'est
solide dans les galas pièces
par contre c'est ben
voilà il a déjà échangé une pièce une de
plus voilà pas à pas méthode de l'anti
jeu est de retour
voilà
donc la garde malingre et blanc ont fait
l'inversé en scène bernard un petit peu
de pièces là il faut garder les tests
simone
de zones d'ombré
c'est de plus en plus durs mois 120
guides d'aveuglés blanc
mais j'ai des petits coups date ont-ils
pas jusqu'au bout car les pieds rebelles
mettent à leur tour ces six tours ses
cinq tours f5 provoqué le fief du
cavaliere le 3
travail améliore
comment continuer si la pro b 6 pourquoi
n'avait sais pas